this program is brought to you by
Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes TC
columbia.edu so I just want you to know
that the message was something that
personally touched me since then I have
become instantly loved it and very
involved in an African shrine and I find
it's very easy to integrate the
spiritual traditions I'm about to travel
to India and go to Temple son Ganesh so
it's about integrating spiritual
perspectives but ultimately were one
community and we have to have a
consciousness of what the next one if
there's all so that we're so grateful
that our community includes from the
hospital so without further ado those
who walk to us only this fantastic video
fair but are here in this community two
teams provide the very best of hiv/aids
prevention services so let's thank them
in advance for all that they do good
afternoon everyone I hope you had a
wonderful day and this is the use of
month okay we are the last presenters
today and we hope you will find our
information useful helpful and something
that we can share with you
Labor Day first I would like to thank
again Reverend dr. Washington I think
your presentation was so meaningful and
timely for all of us so thank you so
much and you are definitely a hard act
to follow but we will do all this I'm
very very proud of the work that we do
in Harlem whenever I have an opportunity
to share with members of the hall
community what Harlem has done in terms
of hiv/aids here it's always a pleasure
so I want to start first by introducing
the wonderful team that's before you and
yourself yes my name again is Deborah
Williams I'm the divisional
administrator for HIV services at Harlem
Hospital and I will just say briefly
that I will date myself when I say this
but I've been at Harlem Hospital for
over 23 years and a very proud of the
work that I've done and 20 of those
years have been working in the field of
HIV in names not only primary care but
also counseling and testing and mostly
HIV prevention and that some of what
we'll talk about today so one the team
won the actor the left of me is as doc
Solomon and he is our consumer events
coordinator and Escott will tell you
later a little bit about what he does
Isabel casada is our quality control
coordinator for rapid testing and then
we have Vanessa Austin who is the
community outreach and education
coordinator and this is an amazing team
I will tell you as we go through this
presentation it takes a team that works
almost seamlessly together to make this
work easy to make it almost seemed like
it seemed like that that you can do
almost anything
they have an amazing way of working
together and working with not only the
Harlem community because we expand
beyond the home community so one of the
things we wanted to share with you today
as some of the work we've done around
mobile fantastic I think most of you
have heard a lot of the statistics as it
relates to HIV and AIDS so I don't want
to go through a lot of that but what I
would like to share is that in New York
City alone there are over a hundred
thousand people who are HIV infected and
what is most profound is that almost a
quarter of those individuals are not
aware of their status so if I asked the
question today how many people in this
audience know very HIV status I'm not
asking you to raise hands but I want you
to think about that if you do not know
your status why and why haven't you
decided to move forward to at least
complete that test to have that
information because knowing your status
is power that allows you to make
decisions and choices it allows you to
engage the medical setting earlier it
allows you to have access to not only
medical care but also clinical trials
and other prevention counseling and
supports that you would need to not only
help you as an individual but also your
family and then your extended family
your community so that's extremely
important so let me just share with you
and the team will share with you some of
the wonderful work that we do and one of
the things i wanted to share just to
give you some numbers today you didn't
see we had three vans outside we tested
for about I guess five hours we tested
52 people that's the power of human
but and for me I would have loved to see
more and so I want us again to think
about this particular model and why some
people choose to enter that then and why
others walk away and many of those again
may not know their status so that's
extremely important so let me just go
through I just want to go through some
of this I want to talk to you just
briefly about Harlem Hospital just to
share with you for those of you who are
not aware that we offer a primary care
supportive services and they include
Cobra intensive case management harm
reduction mental health services
family-centered care women's services
Hep C screening we also offer our
clinical trials in these services are
offered in co-located settings for
adults children and adolescents we also
have a mom baby clinic that were really
proud of that we developed over 10 years
ago where we offer primary care to the
mom when and the baby so when the mom is
being seen by her ID specialist the baby
will be seen by the pediatrician and
that's an amazing model and extremely
successful model so now early
intervention and prevention and why
that's so important what I'd like to do
is to allow the Nestle Austin to just
share a little of the work she doesn't
Vanessa talks about being an education a
warrior and I think that's extremely
important for us to in this setting
share this information
okay recently what we discovered that
our numbers are not going down I'm going
on so we have to elicit an army of the
information warriors so how do you do
that we have to take it to the street we
have to go with people we've partnered
with our faith-based organization not
some happiness be found our warriors out
there is a lot of times when we would
approach a faith-based organization if
they don't eat that we say in your state
by grace a to other people that people
listen to you are the people that have
the power of the word and you can use
that word to pass information like this
disease as RAM Kishan community so we've
partnered with you guys we party with
other CEOs leave it on the beach we've
been at the circle of sisters we've been
at the Javits Center we're going to a
nightclub we need to go away to joy and
you know the joys of the church and
that's where the people are the people
look for the joy and we want to take a
stigma out of HIV testing you want to
make it normally to you and we go to
where you are and we provide the quality
search of harlem hospital and we empower
the community with the information and
their sentence and what I like now as
far as adult to just kind of tell you
about how we do this work how do we set
up how could you set up a mobile van
operation
we must make sure that pollination
skylines of our per year museum or quick
access switches music and we started at
base by planning and organizing
everything that we need incluye
thermometers quality control so that we
can assess our testing location first we
do is to make sure that we monitor the
temperature and one run our body close
to ensure that our test gates are
working properly and we have basically
oils to get globally we have somebody
doing assessments and just one person
doing all the Swami
and if you're wondering what sad thing
is required for such an operation often
what we will do is have not only the
counselors available but also case
managers in the event that we suffer a
hole in andheri closet and the question
for many and I will tell you this was
the question that our executive director
repeatedly asked me was therefore what
are you going to do in community you
find someone who's hiv-positive you have
to assure me that this person will be
safe and we can manage this process our
executive directors of psychologists by
the way so that Palmer was extremely
thoughtful of that process so what we've
been to do is to assure that we don't
case manager available we would ask it
escort the patient with a consumer to
the hospital and necessary we would
provide a house sorry a hotline number
if they needed additional counseling
assistance and one of the other things
that we've done where we find it to be
most powerful is that we also have peer
educators that are available so we have
individuals who are positive who were
watching and are available to meet with
individuals when they are testing on the
vin and have a very different dialogue
with them so I like that stuff just a
little bit
that process that's how I know my name
is Scott Solomon who's zoomin that much
of the changes I'm consumer event for
consumer walking for there for all of
them antenna and primarily while I do
outreach end for the consumer
involvement revenge porn asian we have
over a thousand aw positive patients its
clients to Moscow and a lot of you know
I shudder but you know once you get
tablet to stay but you know HIV you know
think you know you're not going out how
to not wanna do not you make me more so
we were a lot of trips we do a lot of um
bowling boat rides and things like that
because you wouldn't believe how
shut-ins it will be all over fuss about
what this weird want to make you got
that we also have a pedes clinic and one
thing we try to do with it now just a
real rich history for peace with these
these people are born with HIV so when
they turn 18 they have to leave the
people voted Oakland they don't want to
leave that claim so what we've done is
taken take them on trips like they were
going to Broadway play with 18 so now
they will go on the trip with other
adults and positive so now when they
have to leave the clinic if they see an
adult maybe they'd seen them on the trip
they're not added the oh you know like
not feel that Dad about going to the
trip Ruby's history how many tell you I
was a 19 year look in my god you're not
I'm not my god not strike me cuz I bad
person that's right you know I never I'm
not I can't want to share my story hi
everybody you got it I never your IV
drug I'm a heavyset dream man I was
playing football well I knew I shouldn't
be trying to sleep everybody but I with
powerful
this is what we did we have a house
across street from the doorman I go to
class late four o'clock for football
practice come home you want homework we
drink through the same thing and I said
this is what we do this is what they do
God trust him Sam I like this way was
saying I met some very caring loving
individuals like they're on this panel
right now the only miss Williams is one
I'm Isabelle in my work but you know
he's found something so I do a lot of
working community to you know you know
you can have had some loving caring
doctors and you built in people and
you've been looking my eyes I got family
that love you to death still to this day
but it's nothing like looking at
somebody's eyes and I know what you
that's why we employ peers so we may use
appear and oh we can we try to walk we
don't have it all the time and I don't
ask me to slow all the time but
sometimes i do cuz if you have a tough
time you just got diagnosed with HIV you
know you need to you know it would help
if i could show you look hey nice is I
got a full-time job it's not a destined
you know I want but now I don't want to
miss mistake it either it's not a king
that message we gotta keep putting out
soon that medicine might have worksheets
but she knows some other stuff going
around our community and people like
well is medicine now so the angle to get
a medicine might have worked fine okay
so God you know you have to remember so
we use peers you know we have tears I'm
not here I'm a full-time staff but we
still employ me through some of these
tests positive i agree saying people if
you want you people change it to high
school on that day is it's open but who
use me but i have no problem with the
slope you know cuz my family my friends
I have you know I'm okay you know I feel
like that's going to help race of the
stick more we talk by the more churches
core values no banker out more people
talk about it because I'm going to
change remember tremendous but you got a
movie and I'm much a little bit of a
history book metal cancer when we talk
about cancer let you gosh writing now
that was me p is you know overthrew that
that's how a whole country in the world
war i can we on saying get in shape so
this is why I'm not go problem dealing I
wouldn't keep people under stable
because we have to get we have to get
back there like I said I don't feel like
I didn't wrong oh my god why did
anything wrong with my god what now
about the loving camera box a little
while I'm not even questioning why you
know I in the field you know i do what i
do have to like what you do in this
field and thank you so much could you
write about people participate and one
girl who say about me and that's some
sort by this morning on the way here if
you want us you want anybody knew i
would you not to know it nothing that
will go some explain none of those away
plants cause like you street
one man I work you know if you guys
noticed outside we had the Hall of
myself and that's how old man we have
brand new thing he's only shot what we
do maybe I said well because old man you
just have to roll it that's how we just
think that you like it goes with my
father control you will be surprised
quality control we both grew before we
test we talked about testing the kids
every day if I work in two degree
weather under three brothers I am not
exactly outside the Lincoln Lincoln
projects 100 degree weather if the heat
gets too hot in the van next up Kim
cannot test kiss at a certain weapon so
you know it's just a lot to outreach in
your butt you but you have to love it
and um um you know I don't even question
anymore um I do what I do because what
to be honest with you buy that can today
I was kind of like plucked somebody like
pluck me I like I know you need to start
doing some more you know some more work
so that's how I got more if I live
involved in community level clockwork
for the hospital so um that's kind of I
don't want that are you surprised you
know that I asked him to come up one the
stage
10 minutes before we begin a bigger at
all his I think what we wanted to share
was that there are many ways that we can
engage consumers there are so many
people out there that are still there
are so many people that we need to
engage their our foot soldiers warriors
yet to be engaged that we need to
empower our community to make a
difference we need to move from fair to
hope to empower our children looking at
that concept of each one teach one that
if I share information with you then
that empowers you to then share with
others this is extremely important for
us as we move into the 28th year of the
epidemic when we think that when you
think about the fact that the epidemic
was first identified in 1981 and we
still have issues of stigma and fear and
we still have a problem of individuals
not going in for care we still have
issues of disclosure part of the reason
people are not disclosing are some of
what ESCA talked about how will my
community embrace me once they found out
the fear of losing friends family that
still exists
to this day we have individuals that
will engage in relationships and will
not disclose for the fear of the
consequences as a result of their
disclosure so we still have so much more
work yet to do so we empower all of you
now you have the information you can now
be the Warriors you can join us as dr.
Wallace embraced Harlem Hospital about
two years ago and said come on let's be
partners now we can be partners Reverend
Washington now we have that relationship
and we should fortify that relationship
so that next year we can say that there
are some amazing things that we have
done with the faith-based and the
hospital said and what a powerful force
we are now so we will open for questions
if you have any questions and thank you
so much it is late in the day but we
felt that this was important information
to share with you so thank you my name
is Noah friend's mother like to first
thank you all for the great work that
you are doing I come every year to the
conference and I see how I really like
the setting this year dr. Wallace
instead of them being downstairs that
they were in every house you know right
in there you know the vibe is just
really right in there and I you know I
just applaud you for your work my
question is do you go out of state to do
this
we had we have it yet we then asked to
go into bottles that were not that are
not a part of our catchment and we have
gone you know and we've done some work
we've received calls requests you know
from Westchester Philadelphia has asked
us to come out is it a possibility that
you could actually respond positively to
that is what young people and older men
yes let me do let me just say one thing
I'm not sure if you know this at Harlem
Hospital we have an amazing doctor
doctor doctor who works with the
adolescents he has he runs I think there
are four clinic sessions and he has such
an amazing relationship with his kids
that almost a hundred percent of them
who have shared with him that they're
engaging in sexual relationship actually
text I mean he has it's amazing I think
Ashley it was not even going to the
adolescent clinic to work with dr. Jung
ko actually just joined us on a Harlem
Hospital and so we did we wanted to have
younger people involved in the process
so we're really excited about that
initiative with respect to the older
adults we have a staff person in our
medicine clinic and we really paid very
close
to the medicine clinic because that
tends to be where the larger percent of
our patients are and thirdly ESCA will
be joining the neurology clinic so he
will need the male counselor working in
urology oh yes I'll check we do he's me
go back just this week we have
initiatives with youth we're having a
forum in on top of the magic johnson
theatre hip-hop artists pop we're
inviting leaders from six different
youth groups to start an initiative
called get a grip girls empowerment ease
achieving greater resource and
prevention and the youth are going to
create their own PSA judge the PSAs edit
the slicing together here to show the
inter-school process so these are these
are videos good to be prepared value for
you and we go to school regional stairs
its movement through high school last
week and we didn't know that when we
educated to use and we go wherever we're
advice will go also at the Senior Center
we see a serious personal problem
counseling is a fabulous outreach and
education department and they all go all
to all the senior centers in the area
and HIV is invited we go along and we
test the scenes and counsel fees and the
scenes you having sex tube which of the
Spirit amen others named medication and
prevention you know we just have to deal
with
I think it's also important just to know
that you mentioned the ages that we have
from children from infancy and our
oldest was in I believe 80 80 80 80
woman who I will leave I will admit when
I walked in to the counselor sweet that
day I assume she was sitting there
waiting for her grandchild I had no clue
that she was there for her results so
that was very powerful adolescent you
know i did it i tested for like 15 years
now and you know I speak I you know you
dedicate a bit then what I found out
this is what they told me they didn't
see the carnage you know I was in a
support group in the eighties where me
in the early nineties everybody a group
is dead except for me so she dated to be
current well they don't know how daddy
is all right he said so I heard him
Philadelphia and everybody wasn't happy
with it but I will repeat it and it's
really hard because I feel our community
with the talks I do work for eight days
he helped out the corporation all
happens but like I said now that you
will die because the medicine of work
you will die we have to put that message
back out there cuz it's real because
people are still dying it's but the
young young iterations this is seen
acting surprised they don't know that
they see a person like me like or you
don't no no no
oh my i have i said i was for everybody
they don't know that they didn't see me
like all again back you don't ok how to
take risk which I think we have to
reestablish the story and not to get on
history so that's that I need to realize
it but this is worse than the play this
academic diversity play most without the
initial to play it hasn't know my name
is Morgan on for the new Mount Zion
Baptist Church your information visit
HIV normal child my first question is
how colorful and roll original trial and
you have also philanthropic FC oh good
question for the clinical trials they we
have clinical trials for adults and
harlem now and the patients really
should come through the harlem hospital
it's a family care center so if you know
of anyone who's interested we can get
you in contact with that individual and
we have several protocols that are
offered and available to our patients
not only in harlem hospital but also at
our Renaissance healthcare network we
have sites at Lincoln Hospital
metropolitan hospital and st. Vincent's
Hospital for hep-c I believe there is a
clinical trial they're looking at right
now if you give me your information i
will let you know when it becomes
available we have a lot of discussion
about that particular protocol and the
most recent cab meeting that we had so
i'm not really sure if that has finally
you know if everything has been signed
off for that particular protocol and one
other comment I wanted to make about
some of the initiatives next week is
women's and girls HIV awareness and at
Harlem Hospital on Monday put this on
your calendar it's one night only okay
from four to seven we will have an
evening plenty
for partners and what I think so amazing
is that our director of the infectious
diseases department dr. manheimer and
our director of the family cares Family
Center dr. allow will both be medical
providers there and we will offer our
rapid testing STI that's sexually
transmitted I'm inception testing as
well okay no mention of the box under
control this is a national problem it's
the mindset of african-americans and I'm
not saying it right along because it's a
GE not going to involved including
sprouts and that means we don't know how
to miss the work one african-american at
what at Thomas and it works differently
you know because we still had that fear
me why they experiment north I know it
happened to see I also noted black
position right and but for the thing is
we all know people do things wrong but
now the clinical child has both of so
many safe policy they have to compensate
it's the hospital they come presented
when we try to you want to do I'll see
how I am you're not grow
I got out of the question so you know
it's a lot of safe but we have to get
dwelling that put other other community
go to the drop we don't have we got a
lot of Medicine work for us so outlines
that one a lot of things just have to
them come King testing is free but one
person that I know and we know that
we're trying to get health care bill
passed because any hope don't have
health care and how are they handled if
they test that because I know these
holes no we had we have well one we have
case managers available and we now have
several plans that patients would have
access to we have a DAC we have metro
Plus which is a Medicaid managed care
plan and then we also have in some ways
where resource-rich I shouldn't say that
given the economy now but we have
programs tailored for the uninsured so I
share that to say that if a patient is
found to be positive we are providing
care regardless of the ability to pay
very important okay thank you okay yes
I'm happy yep thank you how many other
questions thank you so much no we
actually have 14 minutes Oh spirits
moving you Oh
okay first of all I think your testimony
gar has sent you need for reason to be
able to share with add to that you Mac
and to be able to grow people when they
want to come and use because in biggs my
they are to you my question to you is
that you mention about the people who
shut down once they find out that you
have this virus and they lock themselves
in a home do you have any suggestions or
ideas that you would like to put in
place is always reaching out to those
people to some kind of way that you know
because because the ones that diagonals
and that's going to go for treatment
okay they didn't help what about the
ones that find out about it and then
shut themselves down what happens to
that also cry out for them so is it some
kind of plan that you well okay now just
one moment I don't work on my just for
them doesn't this isn't five mins iRobot
nothing but there's organization that we
find you do what we can do for selective
social myself either party in 228 we had
a little education update I got somebody
take work sadly I didn't know that this
was such a widespread problem I was your
party a couple weeks ago happy is I'm
shot what were you doing you go home
good work so we had to take it upon
ourselves because he I don't blame you
for not disclosing you know I got a good
story about there was the mother they
had me come speak to claim right the
p-doped adolescent clinic and it was a
mother she said West guy I can't come
out in process with you
on your knees because all right well why
not because she's a real I was goin
grandmother type but she said you know
how kids off if they see her with me
they're going to meet between acute her
son he is or not of being possible so
she I understand that so I and I
understanding the clothes because they
are still some you will not believe this
is in 2009 so my told me last week a
grandmother the Sun won't let her see
her grandma was she she go sleep with
the brain can i smoke for that you know
so they didn't still a lot this is why i
don't mind this bloke this is why I
ain't a whole community don't agree with
this why I want routine that I want
everybody and the whole community
doesn't breed with this but I want
everybody walking your dog look I'm on
your test see now if you start getting
some of that that's that thing out of
the way my mind I said if you look at
you in history a lot of things with
sigma x with a defeat kept going and as
we got educated you know and then
equation sports talk about someone
before they they don't talk about
anymore everybody is more dangerous man
I'm hungry loosen strength lives with
you more dangerous to meet you give me
something I can't get rid of all I give
you this HIV now on top of that I didn't
want this but on top of that I conduct
every month I'm interested I don't you
process it that's it my blush good every
month when I before wasn't like that I'm
have them and the S thing about men that
I do with industry and I don't want them
for this is I dealt with if you guys
know when I of course the going home
women here's a man I hope it works out
to the miiverse watching women but but
this but you know how we do and I'm go
get it now you know your husband boards
are not going to we not want to that
must be hectic Lydia and dying hey y'all
be like how's college football player
you all know how do you say I always
thought i'll go ahead and he's an
atavism is always working the soil does
act America man and then you know I
don't know Bobby I think I'm okay I talk
about time I worry about me accusing it
I won't be real important but someone
you know is why I told me it was
important to let the woman help did you
look at man look at me all right i'll
call ask you about a full-time job i use
drugs I can't look at somebody in
champlin school how would you know well
as I reveal the truth 19-year or that
will summon I think it the medicine you
know this is important to me to share
with my sister that happens with women
everybody
look it's somebody i still play basket
ball sack lunch it's a little bit watch
i can't go tonight yeah okay Jeff this
is not so much of a question but i'm
trying linux looming and i found it an
agency in nineteen ninety four children
paris the babies the early pregnancy
planning organization we're watching
Jenny stay with me since the family in
this agency I'm basically here sitting
on behalf of the CEO the community-based
organizations we had the HIV long reach
of the a network with about 15 of 15 or
more nonprofits involved which will give
parents with a the agency that i founded
his guardianship agency where we find
homes for children whose parents will
eventually find it a bit of mines
because of this virus however reason we
put a program in place i frisk you who
have macs out of the home the parents
who have been deceased and what happens
to these children so we put a program in
place where it's a prevention for
poverty incarceration we are concerned
about the young people who want to make
sure that they are tested that they have
a future and they have a plan true to
myself stop my skills in place to help
them we are on sale at in there yogi
years but i just wanted to make that
known to you
paris-based o clock in fact we who have
a linkage here in Harlem Hospital
agreement with the Metropolitan st.
Vincent's so we've been in place as hell
student who works with adolescents I
think that education is key and you know
the notion of having of Education
warriors is vital to not only solving
but stopping and preventing on this
disease but one thing that you know that
information isn't enough I had a health
educator and telling these I lessons
what the risk the fisherman knows you
know and also something given statistics
and they know the information but i
guess i'm wandering thoughts from from
you practice in the community if you
have any thoughts about sort of the
multi-disciplinary things that they deal
with I work with a high schooler who you
know she was pregnant with her second
child and we're talking about the risk
of HIV etc but when she was lying about
her background on the hill I'm what I'm
telling her she's waiting for the bris
benefits of her life the love that she
doesn't receive the self respect that
she doesn't feel and the challenges of
you know being the oldest of I know I
think something like 15 kids and she's
the one who has to help provide for them
and so the activity that she's engaged
and are more important sense of it soon
love then you know the possibility of
putting yourself at risk for a future
that she doesn't even necessarily would
even or see for herself and so in
addition to the education you have any
thoughts of what other activities or
anything else that helps reinforce what
we find in the community testing its
most helpful to listen that clinical
listening because you let them dump
reform their story going out there only
develop start developing a plan for
those a very warm person plan for
themself we kind of give them a homework
you know when you're doing that risk
assessment they said oh not do this or
15 boyfriend's already on 13 own life to
do these acts and I feel powerful and
then they hear themselves there's a lot
of times they don't even realize until
they hear themselves stay out of their
mouth they have that private time with
that persons not their parent we're not
looking at the judgment or not saying oh
my god you did you know it's that
clinical it makes all the difference in
the world just having someone to pour
their heart active and start developing
that plan to take care of themselves let
even know the expression they mean
something we need something to do or
perfect stranger maybe
every opportunity I get what I do also
there are more out of it than you think
and yeah I'm bring up adolescence from
positive 8 they have talked about
messages system sometimes you know they
make me go let's go talking and they
looking like this guy Johnny anybody
know because they say things sometimes
like one day meant you know but I bring
out you know I'll go get my bio get my
24 year old my 21 year old and I let
them talk you know i'll bring them to
let them talk is then you know or women
somebody that identified it because they
doesn't they don't seem that in fact me
I tell you know all these people got I
tell me I was in this important very by
that Dave idea but when I bring out to
change their age it seems it seems to be
able to more effectively there are a
group of young teenagers that in the
churches that believe that they're
practicing accidents because they're not
having something to mount sac to see how
do you have a plan to kind of reach them
because they seem to believe that the
only way didn't actually bigger actually
get aids to that method and because they
feel that they're virgins they're not
using what other things okay how does 0
you don't care how to wish them guess
that every time we do an assessment
every single person not only you but the
seniors the adults a lot of people have
the mist and that's one of the things
we do a Jenny says it's not just
ignoring you instead it's empowering
with the information how can you can
track this how do you prevent yourself
forgetting we talked about we have too
much you're rich you have sex or Lea and
Lea badly any support a lot of people
don't know as a child you can share your
toys you're the dull finish three boys
you can get a disease it's on my FB II
and we talking about how SED increases
your risk for HIV we can spell I've
heard misstep the boy wears boxers I
can't get anything if I drink a cup of
bleach I can't get anything that's one
of the powerful things that we do when
we do a test again for me for the
spelling miss or turn that person around
was full of those lives and turning them
on to the truth and you have teenagers
that are willing to come to the speech
teenager yummy how black because a 0
some of them really don't believe it but
he said they believe that you're older
than we had last year who they were both
of deep fashion divas divinely my
divinely inspired by early aspect the
teenage and they did a fashion show for
50 teens was a beautiful fashion show
music and food when the teams didn't
know that I was going to be there to do
HIV presentation and successor and we
ask the question who in here sexy
everybody makes their hands at all this
everybody goes the problem it would
giggle the other side of the coin part i
do want everyone to be tested for yoga
routine test your routine hospital visit
but now are you abayas is a doctor to
give you a pretest counseling meet you
see when we do that because how we hear
all that stuff
not you I can't get it if I I'm not you
just want money one is some unbelievable
stories you know but when we give that
to the test nouncement we could break
myth because um you know I live in the
field foot foot foot 2015 22 back now
now I understand the transmissions back
there between between between men right
but i just want actual everybody
question that's right question real
quick do we do this again see ya so why
we talk my men having sex with men why
we have the discussion are you mad in
sec I'll kill who what Natalie your
wrist your wrist if you have
relationship with somebody in there
tonight with them that's all I money I
don't keep a quick if you have it you
written I want to get to all that other
stuff I might notice like HIV but when I
used to live in dust off danke she and
her to go adolescence and the ISIL so
like oh you know why you could take this
NC about doesn't come back negative but
what you do how do you like things like
she led the way with how do you tell
people and you said this and like like a
listen to yourselves but what about
those that just like how I should make
all my judgment if I can still go out
and do the same thing that do you have
more more shock widows yeah I think
there are there are a couple of things
of ideas we've come up with one is to
have a series of focus groups with
adolescents to help them to have them
help us design other models because
again this is one of the questions that
there are executive director you know
brought up the other day he said Deborah
you have to come up with something quick
and catchy and let's figure out a way to
do this
to just kind of bring them in so one of
the things we do and we love the use of
focus groups to bring people together to
talk about a common issue and then how
can we best design models to to work
with the larger audience thank you so
much for all of your interested oh how
y'all can t be much anywhere out here me
yeah you know what's interesting there
you the only time your parent has to be
involved is when you come in for care so
you can come in and be treated but if
you come in and you're 13 and you
require medical care then your parent
has to sign okay I'd like to propose a
marriage involves multiple partners
sounds sexy and so if you were in the
audience earlier you heard about the HIV
AIDS education training manual but to
make it very simple what it's supposed
to result in is basically a theatrical
troupe that travels around the community
and educates so we take everything that
we've heard we're talking about the
young people from the church perhaps
people just like you who get together
with other adolescents and you know and
the group makes up the skits it could be
a common scenario girl you know I'm just
taking my cattle bleach and I'm okay you
know I got my man and then the skit
includes up here such as yourself saying
oh come on you haven't heard and it's
funny and it's hilarious um you know my
mission for that manual if you sold the
movie Sarafina how we saw that the play
the movie that is the vision can you a
man
the creativity and the songs and the
theatrical skits that could be so
compelling that somebody say oh yeah can
we need to get that on YouTube we need
to have it on the internet we need to
have dvds of that particular play or
those skits in every single high school
and the every health class has devoted
20 minutes or 40 minutes or however long
it is and that auditoriums and school
auditoriums are also opportunities for
these Live skits and the questions and
answers so I can propose a marriage
between a new Mount Zion Harlem Hospital
and the research fellows because you
know right now we don't have the money
necessary for sure to send sharing to
king of this summer what the idea is
there's an epidemic region in this
community and so what can we do so I
would hope that we could come together
this time next year and then we can show
you a DVD of a skit that has involved
612 adolescents from numele design or
peers from your community from Harlem
Hospital and that we love audience away
because of the power of a marriage in
volume multiple partners I'm going to
thank all of you for saying today I hope
that you have received something that
will allow you to take action and to
have a very commitment to moving our
local national and global communities to
an equity and he'll throw us off
the preceding program was brought to you
by Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes TC
columbia edu